[Music]
let's get to see all your beautiful
people tonight thanks for coming out how
many of you guys have been through tuned
event before wrapped round of applause
maybe for those who have been alright
alright those who have not yet okay
alright good good okay cool cool so
simulation is a daily show and live
event series that features some of the
greatest scientists entrepreneurs and
educators of our time we aim bill
football stadiums with thinkers and
doers and intellectuals we're in it and
see if 22 guys in football pads can do
it why can't the curious intellectuals
do it right all right let's do it let's
do it let's go on all right
I would love to just be like our next
guest needs so eventually Jason Silva is
an amazing super grateful to have him
join us today he's a host of brain games
he is the host of shots of aah you guys
love his videos yeah filmmaker
storyteller the power let's bring out
Jason Silva
[Applause]
Wow what's up guys
thank you for coming out appreciate
having you guys here
and thank you Alan for organizing this
I'm thrilled to be here with you hi it's
such a blessing to have this opportunity
to share conversation with you in front
of this amazing audience beautiful
people
dude I'm honored I know Jordan Peterson
and Michael Pollan recently so I was
just excited to try to follow in the
footsteps of those giants for your
series so thanks for having me I think
that you do you follow really well in
that in those footsteps and okay this is
life is all about you and not at all
about you we have this question that's
come up you made this amazing video
called existential bummer yeah yes you
guys seen that video existential bummer
you know it's funny when I first started
doing shots of awe most of the videos
that I used to make were about
technology and futurism I had read
reycarts Welles book The Singularity is
near when humans transcend biology and
the sci-fi geek in me just got basically
an intellectual hard-on and what I mean
by that was that here was this grand
narrative whereby we would use our
creativity and our technology to
overcome our limitations and become as
gods right and that's what all of my
videos in the beginning were about and
this made me very popular in the TED
conference circles and people that were
into innovation and technology and
transhumanism started to eat up my
content which was beautiful
eventually I partnered with discovery
digital networks which came to me and
said we want to give you the resources
to extend these videos you're doing to
explore all different kinds of topic and
from then from there came the
opportunity to I guess explore different
topics and I think it was our first to
our second shoot we were in Amsterdam
and I did a video called existential
bummer which I think fundamentally is to
be honest the worm at the core the faint
disquiet that haunts our dreams and
existential bummer was inspired by the
work of Ernest Becker Ernest Becker
wrote a Pulitzer prize-winning book
called the denial of death in 1974 and
this book was a distillation of the
human condition as he saw it he was a
cycle psychologist and it kind of built
on the Freudian idea that our neuroses
and our anxiety stems from us being like
sexually repressed and Ernest Becker's
ideas was idea was that no our anxiety
in our existential conundrum is not only
that we're sexually repressed but it's
that we're repressing the most
fundamental horror of all which is that
we are mortal beings mortal beings who
dream of immortality
I remember this professor called Sheldon
Solomon who was featured in a
documentary called flight from death
that put it quite succeed Lee he said
the explicit awareness that you're
breathing piece of defecating meat
destined to die and ultimately no more
significant than the lizard or potato is
not especially uplifting this was this
was the worm at the core it's like no
matter what our aspirations no matter
what our dreams no matter how intense
our love affairs how highs our ecstasy's
like everything was sort of tinged by
this anxiety about ephemerality about
transience and so existential bummer was
an exploration of that tension of that
disjoint 'men right it was like well
here are these cosmic beings that can
dream about the infinite right that can
ponder the infinite you know yet we're
housed in heart pumping breasts gasping
decaying bodies I mean it's like that's
where existential bummer came from for
me
and it's a very personal video and I
think it resonated with a lot of people
because I think it maybe maybe it gave
voice to something that we all have felt
but hadn't quite articulated you know
it's like when it's you know you turn 20
years old or 25
years old it's your birthday you're
supposed to be celebrating but you start
to get like this kind of sadness about
the fact that it's another birthday and
another trip around the Sun and or that
feeling you get when you stare at old
photographs right those sepia-toned
photographs the aging photographs it's
what makes filters on Instagram so
poignant to make something vintage to
age it increases its poignancy because
it reminds you that the moment has
passed but it was a transitory enchanted
moment that is no more and this like for
me it's just like it's annoying anxiety
and I and I think that whether we're
aware of it or not I think it's the worm
at the core for a lot of our mental
distress and I think existential bummer
gave gave voice to that yeah and there's
you do so well at it you speak with such
passion and articulation that you
observe the world in any form it's so
beautifully now thanks bro and we all
know you don't think that way you know
about you
okay so you see this impermanence but
you also want to be creative and leave
behind something that is very impactful
is that shots of awe yeah very much so
so when I when I discovered the Ernest
Becker book it it kind of gave voice to
the sensation I was feeling and a little
pop-culture reference about that book
Woody Allen in the movie Annie Hall it's
a book that he buys for her in the
bookstore the denial of death and he's
like this is the book that will explain
why I'm so neurotic and terrified the
universe is meaningless and so on and so
forth
I believe in that same documentary that
I mentioned where Sheldon Solomon speaks
the the opening line is this idea that
we have emerged from nothing we have a
name we have consciousness of self we
have deep inner feeling we have this
excruciating inner yearning for life and
self-expression and yet with all this
yet to die all right human beings are in
quite the predicament we have the mental
capacity to ponder the infinite yet
we're
I was in heart pumping breath gasping
decaying body so we're gods and worms
and so essentially he he establishes the
human condition and then he maps the
ways in which we have dealt with the
fire in the belly and there's three
historical ways that we have placated
death and put it out of our minds the
first one of course is religion could it
happen before religion right religion
was the first antidote to the mortal
coil you know if you serve God you would
go to heaven you would experience
salvation you you know like follow these
rules and you will live forever in the
kingdom of God I mean it works you know
and the problem of course is that
religion then gets corrupted by humans
and we use religion to justify horrific
acts against one another and it's my
religion against your religion and these
are like immortality projects and we
fight to the death for our immortality
projects and of course you know with the
Scientific Revolution and increasingly
secular outlooks religion might be a
pleasant ritual and certainly Gothic
cathedrals and temples and synagogues
can be beautiful architectural
masterpieces that are amage as to the
transcendent but for those of us that
don't aren't convinced that following
the scripture will make us live forever
we need something else to absolve us of
our terror and so the second way in
which we placate mortality is with the
romantic solution to the problem of
death and the romantic solution to the
problem of death of course you guys are
well familiar with I mean that's like
Western civilization and Shakespeare you
know she's like the wind she's my
salvation she is the Sun it's Romeo and
Juliet it's the deification of the other
it's to find somebody that you can
worship that you can elevate to godhood
and that by rubbing up against this
sacred being you will yourself be saved
as well gets reinforced by the movies
and by the pop songs and by the poetry
and it's beautiful to turn a human being
into a
or a goddess I mean in many ways we are
gods and goddesses we just happen to be
gods and goddesses that die but we are
gods and goddesses nonetheless and so I
think that again the romantic solutions
about death solves that problem
temporarily because you know it's like
it's like that Jewish mystic Martin
Buber talks about ivao relationships
it's like when you truly encounter
another being truly see another person
as a cosmic being and you elevate them
to this position of godhood you
temporarily enter an altered state of
consciousness and which time doesn't
exist I mean to be in love is to be
outside of time it wasn't even achieve
that with someone we don't know by just
looking at their eyes and staying silent
for 15 30 seconds potentially yes we
glimpsed the infinite in the eyes of
another no doubt and a guy called Alan
Harrington in his book the immortal list
says during these moments we if you if
you think of life as like this people
mover like those airport people movers
and you know that we're all patiently
doing our thing and living our dramas
but the people mover keeps going like
towards the ravine that is the end that
is the death of his mitigation of all
there is he says that when we're in love
the altered state of consciousness that
is occasioned by romantic rapture and
Rhapsody takes us out of the people
mover so now we get to co-mingle with
one another as gods outside of time now
I imagine anybody who's ever been in
love ever anybody who's ever lost
themselves in a beautiful song knows
this feeling very well we are absolved
from ourselves in the Rhapsody of love
the problem is it's a transitory
experience it occurs outside of time but
it's still bounded by time when both
ends I know that sounds like a
contradiction that's what seems to
happen it's like well I was outside of
time for three months with this person
them now yeah it's like and and and then
what happens he says is that no
relationship can bear the burden of
godhood because the pressure of wanting
to be saved by a finite being puts a lot
of pressure our gods and goddesses
eventually reveal their clay feet right
and that is such a moment of despair and
or too
appointment and it's [ __ ] up because
it's it comes with all kinds of guilt as
well like how could you be disappointed
in the one that you love because they
couldn't be who you needed them to be
it's like that Radiohead lyric that says
I wish I could be who you wanted you
know because it's a lot of pressure in
the honeymoon phase and the honeymoon
phase ends and biochemically we can't
sustain these states as long as we want
them to and so finally he says that
there's the third solution to the
problem of death is the creative
solution and the creative solution to
the problem of death might be called the
human Enterprise it's what we do with
that anxiety it's how we direct that
anxiety towards overcoming limitations
overcoming obstacles transcending
ourselves building building marvelous
jetliners and cathedrals and wireless
communication technologies and making
transcendent arts and making films and
creating virtual reality experiences and
concocting places like Burning Man where
we can actualize the human imagination I
mean the creative solution to the
problem of death in many ways is the
transcendence of the problem of death
because by many accounts we have become
a geological force in nature right like
if you look at the topography of any
modern city is something David Deutsch
talks about in the beginning of infinity
if you look at the progress we have any
modern city like Manhattan or San
Francisco that physical geography is
it's a bog referring that it's shaped
more more by mind and economics and
intentionality and culture than by
geology so the creative solution of the
problem of death is that our mind and
our collective efforts have now trumped
geology as a force in nature so that's
like our transcendence of mortality in a
way it's still symbolic ultimately
because everybody still dies but maybe
not for long there's a lot of
billionaires in Silicon Valley working
right now to overcome death by
reprogramming our genetics which by the
way will be the most exciting thing ever
once it spreads to all of us
because at first right accessible by a
few people say but regardless shout-outs
aubrey de grey but ultimately Becker
says that that probably the creative
solution to the problem of death even if
it's purely symbolic even if it's purely
metaphorical even if it's just
you wrote an amazing poem and that you
kind of you know hurled yourself into
the abyss and realize that it's a
featherbed to quote McKay like there is
a note that can be like the noble act
the creative act and that allows you to
sort of transcend your death
symbolically and he says it's probably
the the healthiest response to one
conundrum to live a life full of meaning
and full of purpose seems to be the
greatest antidote against this despair
that currently exists and then is that
distributed evenly amongst people the
ability to be creative seems like so
many are trapped in the economic and
political machine well yeah I mean look
if you're hungry you can't be too
concerned about meaning if you've got to
pay the bills you got to pay the bills
but that goes back to the whole Abraham
Maslow and his hierarchy of needs I mean
all these questions of cosmological
significance
Aurra luxury at the end of the day
because it assumes that you were able to
feed yourself for breakfast and that
you're not dying of some horrific
physical ailment I mean certainly I
think in some ways that's why certain
parts of the world maybe that are less
wealthy actually report higher
incidences of life satisfaction and some
bizarre way and it's because you know
like you busy doing you thing I'm gonna
work and you don't have time to ask
these profound questions so certainly
don't have the toxicity of some of the
other things yeah but the point is I
think these questions are only gonna
become more relevant because
technological advances and and
development across the world continues
to pull hundreds of millions of people
out of poverty all the time there's the
best emerging global middle class that
is becoming more aspirational and thus
is more concerned with with meaning or
increasingly will be in and eventually
happens when you get all the money what
happens when you get the one you love
then you realize that's it you know the
game is over
actually Jordan Peterson talks about
that really brilliantly he talks about
the importance of the noble aim and this
is something that really resonated with
me he says the noble aim is something
that you want to move
Ward's and you want to organize your
life around but you taint it because if
you attain it the game is over that's
the problem you want to be moving
towards it and always have it just
beyond your grasp
so that it Orient's you and it gives you
a map of meaning and it gives you a sort
of purpose and an orientation and a
compass so to speak but you know life is
not in getting what you want
life is about fighting for meaning and
it's a lesson that we seem to be
learning over and over and over again
and you got that toy in the toy store
you graduated from middle school when
you got that degree you got the job you
got the car it doesn't say she ate us
you know then these are short-term goals
and then we get to the next goal maybe
whatever the long-term goal ends up
being it is to continuously be creative
in the world so maybe things like yeah
automation and AI whatever ends up
happening in the future will enable more
people to be creative over time well the
problem of meaning is not going away
right I think you have I've read some
reports they're like really develop
societies like in Scandinavia and all
these places where socioeconomic anxiety
is minimal and people it's very yellow
tearing society and people have most of
what they want they have all these
social cushions but nonetheless the
problem of suicide and all this kind of
stuff is really [ __ ] up and I think
that the problem eating is gonna be more
and more even as we become wealthier as
a society potentially and you know the
guy eval no Harare he wrote sapiens and
Homo Day is literally the best book he
says he's wrote an article about finding
meaning in life in an age without work
you know because his prediction is that
our worst fears about technological
automation robbing us of our jobs but
also of our life purpose and meaning is
a very real thing
and now the on the optimistic front yes
increasing advances exponential advances
in technology and artificial
intelligence and all these things will
eventually create a world where people
people don't have to work where the AIS
will be able to take care of most of
what everybody means but it's gonna
leave all this empty space in people's
lives and so what are we gonna do to
fill that space you know and he says
that we're actually gonna
probably fill that space in video games
virtual reality virtual realities yeah
and but here's the thing here's the
thing he says that we already give
meaning to our lives with virtual
realities such as culture identity
religion you know your name I mean these
are these are not biological truths
these are cultural virtual realities and
nonetheless we use them to fill our
lives with meaning and purpose
supposedly so he predicts that in the
future virtual reality systems will be
fully immersive indistinguishable from
the real and we will be able to lose
ourselves in those worlds and undergo
the kind of mythological heroes journeys
that Joseph Campbell vividly writes
about or that our favorite films
beautifully map out I mean wouldn't you
want to be neo in the matrix and [ __ ]
rock it out or ever like I mean I think
that you're in an 80-year one right now
I mean oh what you're in an 80-year
virtual reality experiment right now
potentially if this is all a simulation
as your event postulates but then you
get to design your own virtual worlds
and you get to tweak and play with the
different variables and enter them and
look there's no doubt I think that um
the the tragedy of the human situation
is that we are these exquisite sensitive
thoughtful artists and poets you know
who have the capacity to imagine so much
and to dream so much and either a we
don't have the opportunity to express
that beauty that ecstasy that yearning
because of economic reasons but also
because of physiological reasons you
know maybe maybe you know you had to
work most of your life and then you got
an illness you know when you were 25 you
know you studied philosophy and that it
really puts you into a point of where
you were at when you were in your 20s
and other people don't study philosophy
and they're working lots of jobs and and
so that also makes potentially less
creative beings yes I mean I studied
philosophy because
it was I was lucky I had a mother who
was an artist who kind of encouraged me
to do what I loved I'm aware that that's
a privilege for sure yeah the more that
we can mold these minds into the world
to understand what you're teaching right
now about that essential bummer I think
more people will seek that creative
unleashing into the world I hope so okay
so we have this problem the among human
condition is problematic yes we live in
an age we live in an age of incredible
abundance incredible opportunity but
also increasingly high levels of despair
the burden and the gift of consciousness
is a double-edged sword right it gives
us this immense capacity to create and
to express ourselves and to do
everything we've done look how far we've
come look how fast we've gotten here at
the same time it makes us uniquely aware
that we are finite and we are limited
and I believe that the crisis of our age
is a crisis of meaning and I think that
that is the that is the source of the
high rates of despair and anxiety and
depression and the high levels of
medication and we need an antidote to
the human Kanaan dream I would say and
that's that looking for that antidote is
what fuels my videos that's why I do
what I do my videos are like sort of
these verbal explorations of me trying
to work through you know my own you know
sort of my preoccupation with making
sense of things and finding a way
forward so that's that's where that's
the inspiration behind my work
existential bummer I guess is the
genesis of everything else everything
else is in response to the existential
bummer and this is an amazing way to
unleash that creative potential through
so you kill Kay so we say this is a
crisis of meaning it's a problem and
you're providing an antidote through
shots of awe
what other antidotes do we have how else
can we explain this problem to make it
more relatable to people about how to
find the and yeah so well one of the
ways that I think we can the
the diseases of depression and anxiety
are both characterized by excessive
rumination right our inability to get
out of our heads again the burden of
self-consciousness is that we're
thinkers but when thinking can also
become oppressive because in the face of
death we can be paralyzed to act you
know like to be fully naked and
trembling before the Kosmos is a scary
thing and so it can send us into these
loops of despair this excessive
rumination and self-consciousness which
characterizes anxiety and depression
anxiety is too much possibility and I'm
terrified I'm being torn apart you know
by fear and depression is the cave the
walls are caving in and I'm stuck in
this small reality and I can't transcend
it and so on and so forth but both of
them are characterized by excessive
rumination and self-consciousness and so
one of the ways out is to get out of our
heads and this is where for me I
discovered the power of flow States so
for those of you or not we're not
familiar with flow there's a book
written by a guy called chick send me hi
called beyond boredom and anxiety and
most of us oscillate for the most part
between these two states of mind boredom
and or anxiety and beyond these two
though is the state of consciousness
that many of us are familiar with even
though it tends to be fleeting and
finite but it's a state of consciousness
that is typically fills us with
incredible joy and Rhapsody and this is
a state of flow also known as the
runner's high also known as you know
being in the pockets if you're a jazz
musician being in the zone if you're an
athlete and Steven Kotler and Jamie Weil
who are the founders of the flow Genome
Project they describe flow as a state of
consciousness in which you feel your
best and you perform your best right so
think about that right it's a state of
mind in which you feel your very best so
your blissed-out
but also your levels of performance and
whatever the task at hand is the
triggered flow go through the roof so if
you're a writer that's like when you
completely lose yourself and you know
five hours feels like two minutes and
you wrote the best thing you've ever
written in your life and you feel
amazing and you're energized and you're
pump and it's like haha give me some
more of that
you know if you are a musician it's it's
when you go on some improvisational solo
and you just hear like you you had an
out-of-body experience that you were
like in the audience watching yourself
and you couldn't believe if you were
doing you know I certainly feel
hello sometimes when I do my videos and
that it just totally feels like I mean
the wordix fastest means to be beside
yourself to be outside yourself you know
so it really does feel like you've moved
out of your own way it reminds me of the
movie Black Swan you guys seen that
movie Black Swan it's a wonderful line
where the choreographer is telling her
you know the only thing standing in your
way is you
yeah you know that's a metaphor right
but it's a metaphor saying the only
thing standing in your way is the dorsal
lateral prefrontal cortex which is the
inner critic the inner Woody Allen
that's constantly self-doubting
everything and saying oh it's all for
nothing because we're all gonna grow old
and die one day oh it's all for nothing
you'll never make it or oh it's all for
nothing cuz you're not good enough you
quiet that and then something else
emerges and more curious you and we're
open to you a more present you right and
people experience that as relief they
experience that as liberation and it
turns out that when you're in these
states pattern recognition goes up
lateral thinking goes up risk-taking
goes up so you find yourself doing
things in spite of yourself and that's
where all the good [ __ ] happens right
everything great because of the edge of
our comfort zone everything you want is
on the other side of fear I mean these
bumper stickers are there for a reason
and so you know I came across I mean I
had my own experiences of tapping into
flow it started probably in high school
where I consider myself very much an
introvert and I'm kind of in certain
situations that can be very shy other
situations that can be quite outgoing
but um I stumbled upon certain triggers
that would put me into this zone and my
thing has always been making videos I
used to make like short films with my
with my brother when we were kids and
always making videos I was obsessed with
videos my whole life and and what I
found was that when I entered what I
came to know eventually as a flow state
it felt to me basically as a I would
describe it it's just a poetic reverie
what I just like loosened up you know
and so it's like loosening the cognitive
loosening the mind loosening basically
shut down the part of the brain that was
like second-guessing it was like nah I
don't dance at parties no way stiff
holding back part was pushed aside and
something else emerged and it doesn't
matter what triggers flow I mean
sometimes flow can be triggered from the
adrenaline of being on stage sometimes
flow can be triggered from the
excitement of something that just
beckons you know sometimes flow can be
triggered from breathing exercises jazz
musicians and freestyle rappers love
using cannabis
you know Allegra in California whatever
floats your boat truly but as long as it
gets you there and and what I you know I
didn't know that it was called flow at
the time but what I did realize is that
there was something ecstatic about
feeling in that state of mind because it
provided such a relief from the
incessant chatter that clearly I have to
deal with and so my you know there was
there was a feeling of Grace and
gratitude when I found relief from my
rumination and my existential despair
and so then I decided that that has to
be what I build my life around and
eventually through you know research and
a lot of reading I came to learn all
about flow and the neurobiology of flow
and advances that are happening in the
psychology technology and neurobiology
and pharmacology of ecstatic flow States
there's an acronym to describe flow
called Sturm selflessness timelessness
effortlessness and richness so when
you're in flow your sense of self
vanishes that's the inner critic your
sense of time how time is regulated in
the brain gets shut down so time dilates
and the terror of the passing moment is
no longer there at least you're not
aware of it and finally finally richness
information richness you have access to
more data because all the cul-de-sacs
and error messages of the rumination are
pushed aside so that's all you have to
remember stir self listen it's timeless
in this effortlessness and richness and
that's flow and of course whether it's a
surfer an athlete a musician people who
build their lives around their flow
toward the highest levels of life
satisfaction so there's something to
that right so it's like you know first
start with the human condition and the
existential bummer and then we figure
out okay how can we address this problem
because you know we're here and we might
as well do something with our lives and
so for me it very quickly became okay
these experiences of flow flow and the
art that came from the flow yeah
because on the other side you know
whether you know flow is for me every
time I have flow it's almost like a
mystical experience it's an experience
of the divine of the transcendent it's I
call it the aesthetic orgasm yeah and
and then and then all the content that
comes through is usually in response to
experience of such rapture that it
demands a response you know so if people
are looking to be more creative in their
life I would say the question is not how
to be more creative the question is how
to find so much ecstasy in whatever it
is that make gives you flow and then in
the afterglow when you come down from
that experience you're gonna be so you
have so much creative output to share
with the world that you won't know what
to do with it you know so there's a
relationship between mood regulation and
creativity and so I say you know flow
has to do with mood regulation has to do
with like tapping into that ecstasy of
the present moment and then and then
seeing what happens when you come out of
that lots of creativity for me
so definitely flow I would say has been
for me one of the one of the antidotes
to the human can under me yes
flow being the antidote to the human
condom and then us being able to achieve
it in whatever way we find clever it
were clever beings right we can start
figuring out like what works like what
works for each of us individually birth
into the world we give them a lot of
different options and they figure
themselves for sure if our educational
systems like we're built around what
gives flow through our students I'm sure
that learning and accelerate
tremendously what gives Rob our students
Robin syntax about talks about that yeah
well I went to a Montessori School for
for elementary school and those schools
tend to build a curriculum around the
kids
predisposition and interests what do you
think about this gluing homeschooling
unschooling
I don't know no I'm not unschooling away
from the K through 12 system kid having
a computer when they're young we teach
themselves language teach themselves
math or science or history or art or
create whatever they want to explore and
teach themselves without any guide with
maybe some sort of mentorship or
guidance as well as interesting but what
about the social part and then the
social part as well as very important to
some some kids also don't have an
interest as much in the social part and
they want to just make we had the
resources to build a curriculum per kid
you know a unique educational profile
per student that would be awesome for
sure I support that aren't they doing
something really interesting in Finland
have you heard of this what is it in
Finland the educational system now I
read is being built not around subjects
but around problems to be solved and
problems companies projects require
knowledge in several different subjects
to solve the problem and so the students
end up learning you know about math
they're about science about
environmental studies whatever to solve
the problem we'll take a project basis
but from like elementary school that's
great and they're not showing the sort
of the highest levels of success in
their educational system yeah they're
very sophisticated it's great very
excited with your exciting future of
Education and also very exciting
antidote that you're discovering about
finding meaning and Beefalo States and
also sharing that with other people oh
you needed water should have noticed
okay so in in addressing this you found
flow States with yourself you found
sharing flow states are sharing how
other people can get into flow States I
think a lot of us have an inner critic
within us that is constantly combating
with us don't do it oh it's meaningless
etc and I think a lot of us are finding
that over time to be this path of flow
and of and it just feels great at times
it feels how do you how do you handle
the the times of you know you don't have
someone in your life right now that you
love right
you love your mother and yeah and but
you're not in a relationship so you you
know you've chosen to to not be in a
relationship right now
that love isn't the map right now for
you but the shop knows I'm definitely a
romantic and I I dive headfirst into it
knowing perfectly well it's gonna smash
my head or my heart at the end three
bars three years look so existential
bummer and then flow is one of the
antidotes romantic love is indulgence
that you have to have you have to rely I
treat at this point romantic love more
like like an aesthetic indulgence in
other words like I like the idea of
somebody saving me but it doesn't matter
how many times I'm disappointed and
learning the same lesson that you can't
rely on another person to be your
everything there's still something
beautiful in the attempt are tragic
don't you think like there's something
there's something like agonizingly
beautiful about our efforts did you guys
have received an elephant in the sky I
love that movie a lot of people didn't
like it it was misunderstood film but
the whole premise of that film if you
guys remember the ending is that this
character met this girl Tom Cruise meets
penological was only once in the film he
really only met her like one night and
then the rest of the film we find out at
the end was a virtual reality construct
created for him after he kills himself
and he gets put into this like this
nitrogen freezing thing what do they
call the cryogenics and it's a cryo it's
an advanced cryogenic facility that
feeds you like a lucid dream while you
sleep until technology advances to bring
you back to life and in his lucid dream
he constructed an entire storyline and a
whole love affair where he ends up with
this person right and and the character
tells him at the end when he's finding
out what happened he's like you know you
barely knew her in your real life but in
your lucid dream she was your Savior
right you sculpted your lucid dream out
of the iconography of your youth you
know a movie you watch late at night
that showed you what love could be like
you know that spoke to me so vividly
because it just shows you how much like
these formative experiences that we have
as children rightly or even as teens you
know music album covers movies they
create these archetypes in our minds and
archetypes of love archetypes of
transcendence archetypes of achievement
and then we spend our entire lives
trying to attain those that fantasy in
that wish fulfillment and so even if
it's a even if we fail I think it's it's
it's the romantic part is in the attempt
you know even what you just said right
there putting flow before love is a very
important meaning is that in itself is a
very controversial I think statement the
problem is not loving somebody the
problem is the kind of love that you
think will save you from mortality you
know like that the love that will save
you the way you hope that God will save
you like the problem is the desire for
salvation but that's also the most kind
of beautiful thing about us I think you
know like we will not go quietly into
that good night we will rage against the
dying of the light even if we end up
dying we go kicking and screaming you
know we this refusal of an unwillingness
to cede you know to give up I think is
kind of beautiful and they don't need to
be contentious you can find flow and
then also find love and be super happy
in life okay how about
what is this okay so what about the
Buddhist perspective on things the
meditative perspective that I'm
impermanent totally cool I'm just going
to you know enjoy the time that I have
rather than the rage against work no no
look I think I think the philosophy of
none of non-attachment
I'm not an expert on Buddhism my limited
understanding though has to do with not
holding on to things and embracing a
philosophy of non-attachment
as attachment is supposed to be bound to
the ego and if you transcend the ego and
you don't have attachment you suffer
less yeah and my intuition is you suffer
less but you also feel less you love
less you desire less you agonize
beautifully less you express yourself
intentionally less interesting and so I
think that the you know the the art that
moves me is the art that arrests me is
the art that transform is the art that
pains me is the art that that gives me
an EIN feeling in my stomach like III
like the push and pull the ecstasy and
the agony I think it's what makes us us
I think it's romantic
maybe I'm slightly masochistic but I I
am incompatible with the idea of
non-attachment you know when I look at
my family people that I love friendships
that I love places that I love like I
love those places and those people so
much it hurts right the music that I
love sometimes I listen to a song and I
love the song so much and I'll get sad
from just the thought that I don't have
eternity with which to listen to this
song for you know like I watched a film
like Inception and I'm just like oh my
god I just wished it that I could watch
this film like once a week for the next
million years you know like I just
there's just I get off cognitively from
from arts from ideas and from beings
that the idea that the whole notion of
just letting that go is in congruence to
me but to each his own right it can
there can there be a feeling of ecstasy
with with medicines with meditative
feelings as well of not attaching to
that feeling of ecstasy but you tell me
I don't know either I've made a video of
every insight I've ever had because I
didn't want to just let it go if I would
have get along on attached to the I
thought I was just like you know
meditation sometimes tells us you know
watch your thoughts but don't you know
don't be attached to them
certainly some thoughts are not useful
to attach yourself to but every video
that I made started with the thought
every video started with a thought I did
not let go of yes it was a thought I
became obsessed with I wanted to make
sense of it I wanted to tile it with
language sharing and and making the
video was a kind of psychological
exorcism and it was only through the act
of making the video that I finally was
at peace and could let it go but see now
I haven't let it go now it's a thing
that exists forever in tangible form so
it's my battle against ephemerality my
all art is a battle against ephemerality
so I don't know I mean I
there's non-attachment thing I don't get
it I think it's a way to placate
ourselves against the fear of death is
what I think it's a deathless
rationalization that in the face of no
other choice
you know the maybe the healthiest
response is to find some Nobel
acceptance like oh well it's God's will
for this person to die a horrific death
of cancer God's will you know it's what
God God wanted I just I don't buy it I
think it's a Huracan tragedy
I think illness is a tragedy I think
death is a tragedy you know and we also
don't know what happens after death well
hey I'm sort of envious of people who
are convinced of an afterlife I'm
envious for their peace while they're
alive
but I just you know I can't convince
myself doesn't mean that I can't be
agnostic but being agnostic doesn't
doesn't rid me of you know the despair
associated with infinite nothing okay so
if you do get to live longer and you we
have this era of transhumanism of
approaching us what do you enjoy the
moment or do you have like everyone out
of every five of those moments you have
to record it there's a guy called David
Pierce he wrote this whole online essay
called the hedonistic imperative I don't
know if you guys are familiar with the
hedonistic imperative but he basically
advocates for an engineering of a
technological approach to engineering to
radically extend human lifespan and
eliminate diseases and eliminate
suffering he has this whole idea called
Paradise Engineering and the abolition
of suffering he basically says it's like
let's do a collective human project like
putting a man on the moon to eliminate
human suffering from culture yeah but
not just not just you know the physical
suffering of people but like the
suffering caused by disease the
suffering caused by aging the suffering
caused by mental illness he himself says
that the MDMA like state of
consciousness is a model for the perfect
human state the problem is that MDMA is
in taking too much too much can be sort
of toxic even though it's amazing for
psychotherapy it's not something you can
do every day but he envisions advances
in biotechnology and psychopharmacology
to eventually reprogram the mind you
know at the level of neurons and
neurotransmitters to engender a new
baseline and the new baseline was
something more similar to an MDMA like
state is what he's that's the new
baseline yeah
yeah and well there are some people that
have there's a there's a there's a
syndrome called Williams syndrome they
sometimes call it cocktail-party
syndrome and it's actually very similar
to the MDMA like state the problem is
these people are so trusting and so
loving with perfect strangers that they
can be taken advantage of
yes so everybody has to be on the same
vibe in order for it not to be any
potentially dangerous for the person who
has it but the point is that you know we
there's a lot of different modalities of
consciousness that are possible so many
altered states of consciousness mediated
by different types of drugs hint at the
different possibilities for
phenomenology this is just but one of
millions this is the one that has been
selected for in this kind of Darwinian
competitive survival based guarded
vigilant modality that we need right now
to always plan for the future and
prepare for the worst and so on and so
forth that's been selected for but maybe
that's not what we need in the future
you know maybe in the future a eyes take
care of everything and human beings hang
out and make art and the kind of
consciousness that is required is one
that facilitates being in the present
Michael Pollan in his book new book how
to change your mind he talks about the
psychotherapeutic benefits of
psychedelics you know in in therapeutic
settings to address the pathologies of
anxiety and depression and the book
starts out with this idea that's
fascinating he says that the human brain
as it exists now is like an artificial
intelligence program it takes in data
from the present and compares it with
data from the past and uses that to make
predictions about the future so we're
like an artificial intelligence program
making predictions the brain is a
prediction machine and so what that
creates is essentially a sense of
impatience with lived life a perpetual a
DD and living life in a kind of constant
future tense
he says the funny line is the good news
is I'm seldom surprised the bad news is
I'm seldom surprised right because
you're always predicting the future
you're always sort of a little bit
vigilant not quite present because
always on the thing on to the next thing
and so the good news isn't you know
nothing ever catches you off-guard in a
bad way but equally bad is the news that
nothing ever causes you catches you
off-guard in a good way you're never
surprised you never delighted he always
kind of jaded the been there isn't done
that's of the adult mind and so and so
then he says one of the things that
commends travel beauty and certain kinds
of drugs is precisely the fact that they
block all signals forwards and backwards
so here you are tweaking the way the
bassline works and by blocking all
signals forwards and backwards a
backwards memory right and forwards is
pre modeling the future you get rid of
those signals and you're hurled and
spent into what he calls the astounding
frontier of the present a present that
is literally wonder ful wonder being
precisely the byproduct of that
unencumbered sense of first sight the
childlike wonder the virginal noticing
of the sense8 world that is
characterized with poetic rhapsody and
inspiration and awe and how has all
these cognitive benefits I mean ice
would it be if we could reprogram
ourselves so that our baseline was
William Blake right to see the world in
a grain of sand and heaven in a wild
flower and hold infinity in the palm of
our hands and eternity in an hour I mean
don't you want to live in that state
don't you want to live inside of a poem
don't you want to live inside of a pop
song it's possible right we have to get
our [ __ ] [ __ ] together right we have
to fix things we have to get rid of
inequality economic inequality we have
to deal with people who are homeless and
dying and suffering on the street we
have to address the grand challenges of
humanity which we could already do today
if we just had the will and then
eventually the technologies to do these
things are advancing exponentially
exponential right there are weeks there
are there are decades where nothing
happens and there are weeks when decades
happen exponential is weeks when decades
happen so the progress that we are
already seeing is astounding and
directed towards the right things we
could address the Grand Challenges of
humanity and then we can turn our minds
and ourselves into the ultimate
engineering project to tweak ourselves
into blissful mind-body stakes well we
could essentially be gods in a utopia
beyond time and that sounds to me like a
project worth creating going for yeah
right like
that's a boy can dream we get someone
yeah we this is good to asking Q&A as
well we will be right there in a couple
minutes so so the the stopping and
smelling the rose is in when you're on
the beach really loving the shells and
the rocks there's so many of these
amazing examples when you when you when
you look at your mother look at her like
it was the first time you looked at her
your partner just that that state of not
looking at the past not looking at
future being right there it yeah I mean
some of some of the greatest moments
that a child has are precisely because
he's unencumbered by responsibilities
you know like we also organize our
society in a way that doesn't permit us
to be very present right you got a
hustle and you know you got to be in an
anxious state to get ahead you know and
we've inherited that from the anxious
states of being ahead you know when we
lived in the savannahs of Africa we had
to be one step ahead of the Predators
and now we have to be one step ahead of
our competitors it's the same thing but
you know don't you
it's it's it's even a blade of grass
becomes a magnificent world in itself if
given proper attention like if we if we
were freed from the constraints
burdening that limited Faculty of our
attention maybe we could redirect it
towards just the miracle of being alive
right consciousness itself could be more
indulgent upon its capacities to
contemplate you know I often I'm like a
quote or order yeah but the reason for
that you know my mother's a teacher and
she's taught for 40 years high school
literature and in her classroom walls
she always had beautiful quotes written
like really big all over the walls right
and granted that's literature but
English class is really the class that
teaches you how to be a human being
right you know
Masterclass there's numbers on the walls
and chemistry class there's chemistry
equations on the walls in English class
you have beautiful quotes that tell you
how to be a better person on the wall
mines are like parachutes they only
function when open practice random
kindness and senseless acts of beauty
like these are the causes on the wall
and so I I think I kind of acquired that
same impulse to surround myself by the
ideas that point the way constantly
right the wallpaper of my mind is filled
with quotes that are like post-it notes
that remind me about the states of
subjective well-being that I want to
live inside of so wonder in awe are huge
ones for me I and so I collect a lot of
quotes about that and obviously there's
a lot of cognitive benefits of being in
a state of awe and wonder there's a lot
there was an essay that I read once
called the death of awe in the age of
awesome
and Henry wise Meyer wrote it you guys
to look up the piece it's great but he
talks about out or f scott Fitzgerald
writing about wonder he says that wonder
is a transitory enchanted moment in
which man must have held his breast
compelled into an aesthetic
contemplation he neither understood nor
desired face to face was something can
measure it this capacity for wonder you
think about that when was the last time
you were face to face with something can
measure it to your capacity for wonder
when was the last time that you
completely eclipsed the bin there's and
done that of the adult mind that you
were freed from the tedium of the daily
and thrust into the numinous when was
the last time you had a religious
experience as a secular person and what
I mean by that it was an experience that
carried you outside yourself an
exhilarating neuro storm of such
intellectual pleasure of such cognitive
ecstasy that you basically had a mind
gasm right anesthetic orgasm and that
that that's healing experiences
experiences these experiences make us
whole and these experiences make us holy
what was the Stanford studying on
benefits so yeah this is this is one of
those exam
people's of like science validating
something we know intuitively um
Stanford and Berkeley in other places
did these studies on the subject of all
and if you've seen my videos you know
that this is something I cite repeatedly
but basically uh is an experience
described as one of such perceptual
vastness right such perceptual expansion
that the mental models of the world that
you usually rely upon to categorize
things that's happening to you it's the
bid there's and done that's of the idol
- like oh yeah that's a light oh yeah
that's a person yeah yeah I've seen
those kinds of shirts before oh yeah
it's just another sunset right but
occasionally you encounter something
that's not in your maps as of now those
maps you've built throughout your life
to categorize and put things into order
you encounter something that doesn't fit
into those maps and it can be something
that's genuinely outside those maps or
you could be in an altered state of
consciousness that makes you see
something that was already in the maps
but you're seeing it from a vastly
different vantage point either/or the
point is that during those experiences
you have to now accommodate yourself
enter into a new relationship with this
thing and in that act right equals the
dialectical pattern of reconcilable
estrangement this is David lensing
google it but it's creating you know the
experience offers a distance between
this thing and you and then your new
relationship with it closes that
distance and that act we experienced
subjectively as ah this particular
Rhapsody is awe-inspiring paralyzing
opie ated adjacency
where you're cracked open and the light
gets in like Leonard Cohen says right
like these moments of off I mean they're
but they they're not just pleasurable in
that moment but like I said before they
heal us because after the fact the
studies found people report increased
feelings of well-being increased
feelings of compassion increased
feelings of creativity
[Music]
and yeah those three oh and the
experience acts as an anti-inflammatory
so it has all these like markers in your
body that it's actually it's good for
you so all will bring us closer together
as is everything like the people the
people the people in the in the these
studies about all were in Berkeley and
Stanford but then the studies that are
coming out now treating people with PTSD
anxiety and depression with psychedelics
the stuff from Johns Hopkins University
in the Imperial College of London that
Michael Pollan wrote about in this new
book these studies say that the healing
takes place only when people experience
a mystical experience while under these
molecules and if you look at the
hallmarks if you fill the questionnaire
the William James questionnaire of a
mystical experience all of the
attributes mimic or mirror the
experience of all that I was just
talking about before a feeling of the
sacred a feeling of communion with the
cosmos the feelings of infinite
connection with other human beings a
feeling of well-being feeling of noetic
truth of ultimate reality being revealed
right so mystical experience is mediated
by psychedelics treating people who are
sick from depression and anxiety with
treatment resistance right it's a more
mystical experience the more they report
the healing weeks and months afterwards
same with people who experience aw that
doesn't necessarily have to be mediated
by psychedelics it can be the birth of a
child that could be seeing the Grand
Canyon for the first time you can see
making love to somebody new it can be
traveling the whole point is that we
need to pay more attention to what
happens to us that is so healing during
these moments that arson so you know
economically nonuseful yeah right right
you know you get obsessed with that
flower it's not bringing you a thousand
dollars no no that's but that's what's
so interesting yes oh so it's like we're
so obsessed with productivity now and we
encourage the use of substances that
promote productivity like caffeine
really
but I think we're gonna have to stay pay
start paying more attention to these
other domains of mind the ecstatic
domains and then I'm not the only person
saying this by any means I mean this is
what Michael Pollan talked about in his
book this is what the book stealing fire
that daming wheel and Steven Kotler
wrote that was also a best-seller we
need to pay more attention to the
ecstatic and increasingly as we give up
our jobs to automation in the future
which is happening we're gonna have more
wouldn't have to find more creative and
hopefully more joyous ways to fill our
time is it better to find the ecstatic
in things that are not necessarily
mundane so rather than finding its
ecstatic moments in the mundane can we
craft things that are not yet discovered
by humans and that be our ecstasy is
there one that's better I mean it for me
the ultimate one would be something like
the end of the movie contact like if we
wear with a makeup portal to the other
end of the galaxy and the witness
celestial events outside of space and
time and talk to aliens that would be
pretty awe-inspiring one of my favorite
lines about that movie is precisely when
she says they should have sent a poet
they should have sent Carl Sagan but
yeah man I mean that's what we need that
we need to start doing that like
journeys without and journeys within
let's go explore the solar system and
let's like create virtual reality
engines in combination with new and Thea
genic molecules and explore the inner
solar system to like I I'm more
interested in what's next in terms of
that like what's the next baseline
what's the next base line L so what's
the next what's the next level of like
immersive art like what happens when it
is the theater meets VR meets like maybe
certain molecules that make you more
suggestible and and and facilitate the
suspension of disbelief you know and and
that because you know this the sky's the
limit I think
of the future of art so with within this
art 500 years ago we saw Michelangelo
take years to sculpt Statue of David
years to make the Sistine Chapel with
500 years later we are so heavily
addicted to instant gratification
are we gonna how do you see us
transcending that you're talking about
the consequences of increasingly limited
attention spans because we're always
getting hit with like the next dopamine
hit on the top of our social media if we
used to spend years making of one piece
of art and what well he did well a lot
of a lot of people did there you have
tapestries paintings sculptures filled
or things used to take years yeah I mean
I guess the consequence that now
everybody can be can participate in the
global conversation whether it's by
writing or publishing or making art
means everybody has access but it also
means there's more noise and more
mediocrity
yes everybody's a Michelangelo so that's
always that's like the trade-off right
everybody has a voice but a lot of like
non interesting voices crowd your feed
so that you barely ever see anything
magnificent anymore but everybody has a
voice that's the hi Zoe so maybe maybe
maybe I don't know maybe they're there
maybe the role of curation and maybe
there happens to be a new focus on
excellence yes you know but that's that
can be how we transcend it yeah short
term addictions that we have cake as you
were talking about the cosmic
perspective we do like to ask a couple
questions on the show do you think we
are alone in the cosmos have you guys
heard of the trance engine hypothesis no
okay
so it's a good theory to account for
Fermi's paradox Fermi's paradox is the
one that says that given the size of the
universe of even the observable universe
and given the preconditions that
potentially are there for life how come
we see no evidence of intelligent life
we found all these earth-like planets
all these things in the habitable zone
and then you just infer the rest using
some mathematical equations about scale
and you're like wow there there should
be plenty of advanced civilizations and
yet we see no evidence of it that's
Fermi's paradox right there should be
but there isn't
and so the transection hypothesis is an
answer to that paradox and basically it
says the following if you look at our
own evolution and our technological
advancement it goes in two directions it
goes outward as we spread across the
planet and make massive cities and make
airplanes and then make rockets and go
to the moon like there's this outward
expansion of our technological
scaffolding right like a spider's web
like spreading out potentially into the
universe yet simultaneously there's this
in a word expansion as we make denser
and denser computational substrates
right the chips keep getting more
powerful the processing capacity gets
more powerful and infinitely smaller
until you eventually might get to what
he calls femto scale computing which is
computing that's like computational
density that's on the on the size of it
looks like black hole like dimensions of
computational density okay and the idea
being is we have this outward expansion
but then we have this much faster
exponential inward expansion and no
doubt eventually maybe a couple hundred
years whatever we're gonna live in
virtual realities because that's just
what can happen synthetic artificial
intelligences that can think and
essentially have personhood will live
inside of these virtual realms inside of
femto scale density computational
substrates so we're gonna basically open
up a virtual universe that's operating
in dimensions that are smaller than the
more dense than a black hole so we will
disappear out of space and time out of
the visible universe through these scale
data and and so transection is basically
that we like we disappear into into an
outside of space and time and that's
when we find all the other advanced
civilizations so they they went in is
about mm-hmm that's transection that's a
real thing coined by a guy called John
smart you can google it I made a video
about why we don't why we don't we
haven't found the aliens I certainly
don't believe any of the reports of
flying saucers or anything like that
don't sound more like psychedelic
delusions that's a really good one
though transection hypothesis that's a
really interesting okay and then do you
think we're already in the simulation
I'm gonna read a passage to answer that
Latian hypothesis like whether we're in
a simulation right now like I just think
it can be argued either way but one of
the things that um you just argued for
transition hypothesis yeah yeah but but
listen to this so um Kevin Kelley talks
about he started Wired magazine he talks
about a series of discontinuities that
have changed how we see ourselves in the
cosmos the first one was when we thought
we were the center of the universe and
then we realized we're just a little
speck of dust in a sunbeam and then and
then another discontinuity has been the
one that we think that we're like
somehow special and the other animals
are not like gods and they're not and
then we realized evolution though we're
the same we're on a continuity so the
discontinuity was was illuminated again
the third one that we're going through
now is that we think ourselves as
different from the man-made or the
human-made so there's the natural the
organic and the human-made is somehow
unnatural but increasingly we realized
that we're just smack in the middle
between the born and the made and that's
another continuum and the Technium which
is the Kevin Kelly phrase for the
organism that we call technology he
calls the seventh kingdom of life so
technologies we realize is just
continuous with biological evolution but
then the last exceptionalism and it goes
this idea of whether we're in a
situation or not v discontinuity is the
special status that we give to the
physical we feel the universe to be a
physical material that pushes back and
presses and presses against us things
have weight size and duration that's
what the universe is an everyday
experience the real stuff that can be
measured felt and sensed our world of
matter and energy follows a set of laws
to such an exacting degree that we can
manipulate it to make rockets and
computers that's pretty solid matters
consistent refusal to be bullied outside
of its own laws adds to the sense of it
being real right real means physical
right information on the other hand
lacks physicality unlike energy which we
can at least measure with physical
instruments a digital bit is disembodied
it weighs nothing it takes up no space
we don't have good measures for
information we are not yet sure if the
total amount of information in the
universe is conserved nor if it is
finite yet we have come to see that life
even our own life is a pattern of
intangible information rather than
material form evolution that great
engine of creation is a pattern of
information and mind especially the mind
is a type of information flow so we know
that the most powerful forces in the
universe that we are aware of are
constructed of the most intangible
things we can detect bits there stands
the discontinuity atoms vs. bits but
lately physicists have become to suspect
that atoms themselves are composed of
information in some way that we don't
understand as the legendary physicist
John Wheeler puts it it's our bits the
deeper we inspect the interior of
subatomic particles and their quirky
behavior the more they can be explained
as information flows many physicists
expect that when we get to the bottom of
how matter works
we'll find primarily a structure of
information and the absence
vanishing material atoms will be
understood as elaborate dynamic
arrangements of intangible signals
solid-state physicists David Merman
writes matter acts but there are no
actors behind the actions the verbs are
verbing all by themselves without a need
to introduce nouns actions act upon
other actions
there's no duality between the existence
of a thing and its properties
properties are all there is indeed there
are no things as this discontinuity
between the realm of the physical and
the realm of the immaterial is erased
scientists have began to re-envision the
laws of physics as complex algorithms of
code energy also is being restated in
terms of information the pulsating stars
and iron planets will gradually be seen
by science as wisps of intangible
nothings organisms and technologies
including mega structures like
skyscrapers and starships and floating
cities will be defined as structures of
computation equivalent to software so if
that's the case yeah then yeah yeah
really happy that you read that Jason
last question and we'll open up for Q&A
last question is what he thinks the most
beautiful thing in the world
whoo
so I recently uh I underwent an
experience of psycholytic therapy which
is with a nurse who has a degree in
psychedelic assisted psychotherapy to
take care of me to address some related
issues that I had with anxiety you know
I deal and one of the things that I that
came to mind during that time was that
the most not just when something is
beautiful but the sensation that it
occasions
right the feeling of beholding beauty
right is the most exquisite and
important thing in the world and by the
way that's a big umbrella term you can
include love under beauty can including
aesthetic experiences under beauty but
but I just think that to me the most
beautiful thing in the world is the
cognitive and aesthetic orgasm which is
the moment in which you commune with
something magnificent beyond yourself so
it's a moment of revealed truth and
ecstasy and merger and communion and
it's when you cry not from sadness but
from ecstasy right
why does beauty make us cry ask Alain de
Botton and he says it's because what it
hints at is the exception and so there's
this cognitive dissonance between what
you're seeing and what you know the
average to be and in order to correct
that imbalance you cry it fixes the the
discontinuity there and that's called
catharsis I love you know but but you
know you can be you can have an
experience like watching a film and a
film builds up slowly and magnificently
or a melody might do and you know it
works - have you heard George Peterson
talk about music and how it speaks
meaning to people it's the one thing
that cynical people can't be cynical
about and I feel the same way about
about good films you know they're they
speak meaning they broadcast meaning you
know and and you know we're meaning is
like oxygen for us you guys know that
line that says you know human being can
live for you know a week without food or
three or four days without water
can't live for a minute without hope
right people commit suicide when they
lose hope meaning is the antidote to
hopelessness meaning and significant you
know
this is everything and and so the
capacity of music and cinema to to the
way it delivers meaning to us the way it
patterns it you know like like
melodically
and then like spoon feeds it to us you
know is almost tantric in a cognitive
way you know it's it's it's to me it's
everything and and and to regularly
submit you know talk about surrender the
ecstatic surrender to a work of art to a
work of meaning I think is the the
greatest possible indulgence that we can
give ourselves amidst the cosmic tragedy
of being finite beings who dream of
immortality so that's like the temporary
fix until the singularity makes us all
immortal and saves us so yeah what a
wonderful conversation Jason just super
blessed I've had you in San Francisco
I've been here we all greatly appreciate
you and love your work so much and we
hope to hope to see you again very soon
thanks bro
thank you take some questions you an a
now
we are ready for your questions
Jason is ready Mike is right there if
you can get up and go to that mic that
would be fantastic you guys have a good
time tonight yeah good good really happy
to hear that all right question hey I
really wanted to talk about the VR
theater idea that you had the wasn't
what VR VR in theater we are in theater
oh yeah cool I was wondering if you
could expand upon that sure um have you
ever read a book called Hamlet on the
holodeck Hamlet and the holodeck
no okay so Janet Marie wrote this book
the holodeck from Star Trek you know
that room where you go and it's a so
Hamlet on the holodeck is a book about
immersion which is the the word that we
use to describe that magical feeling
when you assume the mediated reality so
it's you know you go to a theater and
you're you're kind of restless like when
this is gonna start and you know and
then you're like you have to pee and you
know it starts and you're still thinking
about work and whatever and then like if
it's good right if the acting is good at
the thing is music is good if whatever
is good if you didn't eat too much
you're not too fully or whatever all of
a sudden like all that other [ __ ] you
were worried about gone and now you're
like fully [ __ ] invested in the
narrative like as far as I'm concerned
that's the holy grail of media when it
immerses you fully and the better the
media the more satiating and satisfying
the immersion so now we you know it
already exists to a certain degree good
movie is brilliantly immersive a good
play is brilliantly immersive because we
can broadcast our mind from the seat
into the screen or into the stage now
what immersive theater this new genre of
theater is trying to do is get you out
of the seat and embodied in the world so
it's the next step all of a sudden you
have agency you can move around you can
interact with the characters
actor's actions can change when they
interact with you the most famous
example of immersive theater is in New
York City sleep no more punch-drunk is
the British company that did this and as
far as I'm concerned
like they cracked it you know the
virtual reality dream of like being in
the movie where you can move around they
did with analog theater so I mean this
is a some kind of hybrid of like
Hitchcock and Macbeth and it takes place
in an abandoned hotel and it's seven
floors and you go in wearing a mask
that's what like distinguishes you from
the actors so all the audience is
wearing these like Eyes Wide Shut styled
masks and the whole thing is super ear
in a stage design and the lighting and
the music is magnificent you hurled into
the world and then the actors that are
sort of dance performing a version of
Macbeth all over the hotel but you never
know from where and how or when
so you're just lost in this world and
occasionally pieces of performance you
stumble into pieces of performance while
exploring and then you you can follow
the actors around or you cannot but the
feeling is very much like being in that
lucid dream you know
yeah and so the idea being that
eventually this kind of immersive
theater where the audience's
participation and agency will be
combined with things like augmented or
mixed reality interfaces where you can
wear like some kind of you know maybe
the those lenses that came out that can
put digital artifacts and add elements
to that and then there's also the idea
of like fully immersive virtual reality
where you're sitting in a chair or
you're on a treadmill and you can walk
around some kind of a world but I think
that has a ways to go before it can be
as dynamic as the analog version you
just grab the mic and move it up towards
you like you have a stand yeah perfect
just like that thank you
well I'd say well the first thing I'd
like to ask is I thought this was gonna
be what you were gonna chronologically
show your shots of all we're gonna get
to view it which is not the case so as a
fan will you be willing to do a shot of
like to freestyle something like that in
front of us that's
that person the other thing I wanted to
say is in the field of electronic music
you can go anywhere in the universe and
as you as a futurist have you ever
thought of maybe doing a narrative to
guided meditation or thinka tation so
that we can view some type of meditation
in your world where we go into an
altered state with maybe binaural beats
that slow our brain ways or put us in in
all the states are you there would be a
waste where you can never do that I hear
you man
thanks for your question yeah this was a
little bit different because the format
here was just a fireside chat I have
done these events typically I do like a
25-minute talk in combination with the
videos which is great because it
introduces the work to people and it
gives examples of what I'm talking about
we didn't do that this time around but I
mean hopefully the conversation because
it was unscripted give you a sense of
freestyle I loved it to be here with you
is just amazing thanks for coming and as
far as like recording something that we
could you know like you know nobody's
ever done that I mean a few people have
where they take snippets from either
podcast interviews or some of my videos
and they mix it with electronic music
there's a couple of DJ's that have sent
me sets or they use my voice super cool
I've never done it deliberately in
partnership with somebody but it would
certainly be interesting to do yeah I
mean as far as like in the field of
electronic music I know the best and if
you ever wanted to or not you know you
have to collaborate with me I'd love to
maybe we're actually writing it a
narrative and saying this is what I'm
gonna do and we're gonna put some music
to it well I mean I have plenty of stuff
that uh that is audio without any
post-production that I could give you
and we can send it to everybody that
came here came out of this
yeah and my name is Rocco Anthony for
misko and I asked you one time what is
enlightenment to you I don't know if you
remembered but maybe you could tell what
what is enlightenment to you you said
you weren't enlightened but you have
these classic little mystical States and
you didn't think they could be you know
just sustained like the Buddha talk yeah
you know what it is I've had profoundly
[Music]
moving and and aesthetically relevant
experiences that have shifted me that
have seemingly transformed me that have
inspired my work and my career which in
turn has inspired others so clearly
there's a digital paper trail that shows
where I have been I mean my my videos
might as well be referred to as trip
reports for sure however I think I'm so
terrified of being disappointed that I
don't cling to the revealed truth of my
videos too strongly I have the
experience I make a video about it and
then typically I I kind of go back into
my baseline of openness but also I avoid
drinking my own kool-aid yeah and and I
think the reason for that is because
there's a terror that I'm like one of
these moments feels like now I
understand how life is I had a mystical
experience and I'm one with everything
and everything is perfect yeah and then
my friend tells me that his mother had a
tumor on her kidney how am I supposed to
like how's that compatible with a
mystical universal Union that I had a
day before you know so it's like it's
like I see the homeless people in San
Francisco and then I'm just like so much
suffering on the street and we ignore
him okay yesterday I wasn't in a
beautiful song feel one with the
universe and now I see people suffering
on the street it kind of negates the
oneness I had with the universe the day
before and so that's why you know my
enlightenment always feels short-lived
so far
so but it keeps me humble right because
a lot of people who are enlightened
become overzealous self-righteous gurus
you know and selling false truth you
know and I I think it's more human to
admit that we're full of holes and we
have moments of clarity and insight and
moments of confusion and doubt well I
won't keep these people waiting but yeah
thanks bro how do I collaborate with you
just email me through my website I'm
really good like that yeah all right
thanks bro Thanks so I love to put
myself on the edge so I forced myself to
do something that I usually would which
is come up with a question days before
awesome and through those past two
questions that kind of cultivated a new
culture within me to ask this one which
is it kind of seems like the narrative
through all of these talks and whatnot
is solving that kind of existential
angst that we're collectively having
after we solve this humanistic need and
getting into the frontier of
existentialism and what comes next so
really it kind of sounds like this
narrative of the singularity and whatnot
is going towards just building more of
the same the same bubble almost so when
does it get to the where is the point at
which I mean it's kind of like almost
the way that I see it is building upon
building the the mind but what's beyond
that are we just going to become slaves
to the mind of building connections upon
connections until we become the universe
or is there something more I
I'm not I'm not sure what comes next man
to be honest I you know I think well
Kurzweil certainly thinks the father of
the singularity that we will infuse all
matter with intelligence so at that
point right now kind of intelligence
that we recognize seems to be housed in
this amazing three pound flesh computer
called the brain but if we could infuse
everything then it's you know Kurzweil
says the universe will wake up
certainly the beginnings of this right
now we call it the Internet of Things is
a version of extending exterior izing
our minds by infusing everyday objects
with feedback and with intuition and
with artificial intelligence and
creating a world where a lot of the
boundaries between ourselves and the
world start to disintegrate because
we're increasing then I live in a world
that responds to us and they can predict
our needs and it can offer us a drink
when we're thirsty and so when the world
starts to have as much agency as a
highly advanced version of Siri it's
already gonna start to feel like we're
living in a world that lets like a
return to animism like indigenous
cultures would talk to trees and talk to
stones you know it's gonna be digitally
mediated animism the world will sort of
come alive and at some point when the
level and sophistication of the feedback
we get from everyday objects you know
and even in the short term is of a
fidelity that's high enough for us to
respond to it and it responds to us
intuitively will stop asking the
question of whether it really has
consciousness just like we stop asking
that question of each other because I
don't know if any of you guys are fully
conscious and you don't know if I am I
could just be a zombie that's pretending
to be conscious same goes for you guys
but at some point we just suspend this
belief we just accept the fact that a
person is conscious based on the
intuition of the feedback loops we get
from that person and so I think that's
kind of what will happen like will
impregnate more and more of the world
with with mind is I think that it's kind
of where we're heading if
you can map our technological trajectory
now whether what that means
metaphysically is up to the poets and
the artists yeah
as a poet thank you um and yeah that
that fits in right with the idea of we
are a prisoner to every prisoner we hold
in prison because there has to be a
guard for every prisoner
so as we allow the world to be more
conscious than we ourselves will have
more consciousness to experience in the
world thank you I hope so thank you bro
hi I'm Asher thank you so much your time
is amazing Thanks yeah it's uh I love
the way you talk about Fermi's paradox
and I'm like really interested about
paradoxes like I made this video in
college and it was about me meditating
and like self actualization and
realization of my true self but the
funny thing was is like I didn't even
meditate
really back in college but now I
meditate all the time and so I realized
like oh my god this is like what I was
working towards was this like amazing
space and time where I could become like
you know the singular meditation so I'm
wondering like how do you grapple with
paradox and like how do you make sense
of that paradox like every oscillate
between the two things that are in
conflict you know what I'm saying like
it's like for me it's paradoxical in a
way that you know we even like you know
we feel conscious and yet we're told by
neuroscientists that the self is an
illusion you know there's there's kinds
of paradoxes that we grapple with every
day we feel you know at least young
people feel immortal yet we're told that
we are mortal like we live in doubt you
know science has done a really good job
of explaining the world but then there's
new things that emerge that call into
question everything we thought we knew
so we're constantly thrown into
situations where we have to live with
two seemingly contradictory ideas and
somehow live in the presence of both
it's tricky but we do it awesome yeah
thank you so much thank you bro
actually that's one of the hallmarks of
a mystical experiences paradoxic ality a
feeling that the two seemingly opposing
things suddenly fit in a larger model of
reality that you're privy to psychedelic
studies so first of all thank you so
[ __ ] oh hey Matt say hi Rick a lot of
challenges in the community around the
future of psychedelic medicine there's
approaches that Maps is doing in the
nonprofit approach and then there's
for-profit approaches and I was just
wondering any wisdom and how we can do
this work in a way that's conscious and
changing society and and aware of sort
of the social structures that we live in
since you yeah I mean what I would I've
read it Michael Pollan's book is the the
concern about the medicalization their
psychedelics so yes these controls that
were putting in now with these studies
are important because we can't afford to
risk what happened in the 60s when the
exuberance got so out of control that we
pissed off the wrong people and the
research was halted so I think that the
careful approach that they're taking now
is good and the baby steps are similar
to what happen with cannabis at first
its medical but then eventually we got
to recreational I think we can kind of
follow a similar model you know it's
harder for the powers-that-be
to say no we're not gonna let you use
this even though it's helping people
with treatment resistant depression and
anxiety and so the medicalization
approach I think is a great first step
but what about the idea of making well
people better I mean aren't we all in a
way having like micro PTSD don't we all
suffer from at least a little bit of
depression and anxiety I mean for some
it becomes pathological when they can no
longer function and hold down a job and
so on and so forth but I think the rest
of us are just better at hiding it you
know and so I mean
what happened here when super-successful
achieved people killed themselves all of
a sudden I mean what does that tell you
about the seemingly well-adjusted and
successful so but I think the
medicalization approach is a good first
step and I think eventually it's gonna
be more like you know like going to like
like a spa it'll be like a place that is
licensed with licensed psychotherapist
and but then aesthetically they can be
whatever you you're into you know it can
be like a jungle spa psychedelic
wellness spa and there can be like a
singularity future is this psychedelic
spa a cosmological psychedelic spa you
know cuz one of the things we've learned
about these medicines is that their
effects are 100% constructed by setting
setting an expectation so you know if
your interpretive frameworks are of one
culture indigenous culture then the
divine will present themself to you in a
particular wallpaper and if you're a
Christian you know it'll present itself
in the form of Jesus and if you're uh
engineer to present itself in the form
of a solution to an engineering problem
and so I think it'll be maybe the
psychedelic spas of the future which
will be will be like restaurants well
you pick your cuisine you know but
they'll all be regulated just like
restaurant food quality we've read it
regulated and and the cooks will have to
be clean and regulating or like I think
maybe that's the answer in the future
you know thank you for your support in
helping make that happen
yes well it's uh the mind is ripe for
exploration and so you know if we can
help alleviate human suffering and learn
a little bit more about consciousness
and treat these things as tools then you
know it's a tool and if used in the
right way it can solve a problem and if
used in the wrong way it can be a weapon
right I mean a hammer can you know be
used to put nails down or it can be used
to hit somebody over the head so it's
how you use the tool
right there so first off thanks for
coming down and talking to us it's been
really interesting listen to what you
got to say amen but what I was thinking
is you were talking earlier about the a
global project to eliminate human
suffering yes we exist in the euphoric
MDMA state now what I was wondering is
do you not think that to some extent
suffering and adversity or a necessary
part of the human condition search for
meaning the arguably having things like
bliss and euphoria and happiness might
not even be possible without the angst
and the depression and the suffering the
counterpoint that with that's a
fantastic question and I'm actually I'm
actually inclined to agree with you I
had an insight the other day my friend
he's super excited because he got a
Tesla and he was we went to like a road
where he could like accelerate a little
bit to show me like pickup with her and
you know who that initial feeling of
acceleration is like a reverse dolly
shot in a film you can liken it to the
moment when a character is having a
realization where his reality has
shifted from one to another so again
back to your notion of contrasts you
know the reverse dolly shot in the movie
works because you're temporarily
disjointed and disoriented as you move
again from one perspective to another
through the eyes of this character
acceleration takes you from one speed to
another once you reach a velocity you
don't feel the speed anymore really it's
only during the acceleration which is
the shift from one to the other
so perhaps you are right perhaps ecstasy
is more meaningful after having overcome
adversity no doubt you know that's why
there's a thrill of the chase and then
there's the thrill of attaining what it
is you were chasing and then you have to
start again because once you get what
you want the game is over so but maybe
these are things that we can build and
design into our life projects whether
they happen in the flesh world or in
virtual reality you know I still think
we can eliminate the suffering of
illness and the unnecessary suffering of
people starving and that kind of
suffering I don't think that that's
necessary to give our lives meaning I
think we can maybe inject artificial
dramatic suffering just like a good
movie has conflict
but without having to have people dying
of cancer or rendus other painful
diseases
thank you very much fun excuse me hi hi
upon everything that you said I want to
hear yours so upon evolution I wanna ask
what if whenever we feel or there's part
of our brain that lights up and in the
happenstance of the virtual reality then
it always got gets turned on those gets
turned on but so what I'm saying is what
would that how would that affect
evolution so upon the over axis of the
turning on of the all that fuels have
then the thing that virtual reality
would induce would lead to an evolution
of turning off I'm not sure if what
you're asking is this but I think are
you saying that if we figure out a way
with our tools and technologies whether
it's virtual reality or other strategies
to give ourselves experiences of awe on
a more regular basis if then that will I
guess over many many many generations
transform us because we are using the
part of the brain that registers all
more often is that what you're asking I
think it might take a long time no it's
not
okay so let me explain it first so upon
your thinking process what is the part
of our brain that fuels or will always
be turned on and thus inducing the other
parts of her head ever evolving into a
smaller form so the other parts of our
brain would atrophy because we're not
using them as much I mean III think it
would have to be many many many many
generations before our brain showed like
some physiological change due to more
exposure to our I'm not a scientist so I
can't explain that as accurately as I
would like but thank you for well the
base line going up and and what happens
after that but that base line would have
to be engineered to be different that's
different than just evolution having you
selecting for a different baseline you
know David Pierce advocates intervening
going in there and changing [ __ ] anyway
hey yeah great question um what's your
opinion for those that don't know like
Venezuela is collapsing it's basically a
failed state inflation is like at a
million percent this year the government
is basically a narco-state they've
censored all the media they've arrested
all political dissidents they rigged the
elections they've turned down
humanitarian assistance for the people
who are starving and can't get access to
medicine but they wear this banner of
fighting for some like Cuban style
socialist dream with no freedom for
citizens of course and they've basically
pillaged and raped the country the
corrupt government in the history of the
country
and so being from there and you know
seeing firsthand what has happened I
think that we need a bunch of nations to
get together and send armies in bro how
would you say that the sort of Internet
of Things and the extension of our mind
in VR has affected culture the way that
we sort of interact with each other wait
see that again how would you sort of say
that the Internet and the extension of
our own collective minds into a digital
space has actually affected our
interactions with one another not purely
on a digital realm so you think that
because we've spent so much of our time
interfacing with screens how has that
affected how we interface with each
other yeah I think it can be argued both
ways you know I think people love to say
oh we never pay attention to what's in
front of us because we're always on our
phone but nobody ever stops to ask if
maybe what's on our phone is more
interesting than what's in front of us a
large amount at a time you know like I
mean sometimes you are watching an
astounding video on YouTube and you're
uncomfortable commute in the subway in
New York and the heat to work and rather
than staring at other miserable angry
folks you'd rather watch them an amazing
video to take you out of your head to
make the commute a little bit less
miserable and that's an example of like
hell yeah give me some escape but maybe
other examples is like you know you're
at a park by yourself there's a lovely
lady there with her dog by herself and
you don't notice each other because
you're both on your phone oh well that
sucks too you know so it can be argued
it can be argued both ways man see it's
hard for me to pick a side because I
think it's all contextual you know there
are some ways you know I owe you all
being inspired by my work is thanks to
this you know but the problem with this
is also when this
comes at the expense of not leaving room
for face-to-face moments that are
meaningful I think it just it just puts
the responsibility back in our shoulders
I think to self curate how we deploy
these tools you know that's okay for now
hi Jason
Hey I was impressed by the early
discussion about romance and well I
don't know I just wanted to thank you
for that human moment part way through
where you were talking about like
gathers that there's the pain and the
agony of it and sort of part of it as
the meaning and it's all intertwined but
um yeah I mean even even before you ask
you a question you say to that because
you know this is something that I used
to do a lot I haven't done it as much
anymore and maybe because I've lost my
tolerance for pain but when I was I've
made videos all my life I really have
you know now I make videos of love and I
put some stock footage of generic humans
that aren't directly related to me but I
used to basically make those same videos
and then the cutaways were to my
girlfriend you know and when I was
deeply deeply deeply in love that was
intertwined with obsessive documentation
I was constantly recording what it was
like to be in that interest subjective
space and then I was looking for words
to describe that ecstasy and I would
take that footage and then I would edit
it with the most heart-wrenching ly
agonizingly sad and beautiful melody I
could find and lay that underneath and
then review the footage even from the
day before of me and this girl I was in
love with right and what was amazing is
within two seconds something that was
twenty-four hours ago was made so
poignant I was like I felt like I had
lost this person even though they were
still in my life and it was in mimicking
the feeling of loss that it made me
appreciate them more before I lost them
so in a way it was like jolting myself
into realizing house
it is to be in love with somebody and it
required an aesthetic act to bring
attention to it I needed to make the
video I needed to put it to sad music
you guys ever see the movie lala land
the end montage of lala land the dream
ballet that replays the whole movie with
beautiful music and all the images is
what could have been which should have
been what might have been that poignant
feeling of looking back that melancholic
sadness and it shatters you and the
reason it shatters you is because it
makes you realize how much you didn't
fully appreciate what you had and I
think that that's always been the
tension and the dance that I've had with
love it's like I created artificial
suffering as a way of making me more
present and appreciative of what I had
yes you know and maybe it's because my
intuition knew that nothing lasts
forever and I was like well I'd rather
grieve while I still have them because
then I can actually hug them in the
midst of that sad ecstasy rather than
wait until they're actually gone and cry
by myself
weird [ __ ] I've been doing but that's
what I do and I haven't even gotten to
my question well I was struck by what
you were saying with regard to having
several solutions to the problem of
death to putting away the anxiety and
the discomfort that comes with the
notion that you will eventually die much
that you care about as well and religion
being one solution love being another
solution and creative pursuits being a
third solution or the pursuit of flow in
particular and I mean you when you
describe flow and you describe creative
pursuits and creative states you use
much of the same language that you might
use to describe romance much of the same
intensity much of the same all and the
kind of question I have is basically
that in noting that it's clearly the
case that you can't sustain the second
solution for well you know one's entire
life or even just more than 12 months
you know it's essentially
insensible to to rely on that but maybe
you can you can use the similarity
between these things and and it's like
the sustainability of creative ecstasy
is something you can repeatedly call it
into being right it's not something that
our tendency to be awed by creative
experience doesn't just diminish after
three months it goes in cycles you can
always get it back you just need a
recovery phase
you know after deep deep deep flow I
might take like a day or two where I
just need to chill but the flow cycles
yeah as long as you follow the rules of
the cycle cycle and you pay attention to
your biochemistry potentially yeah you
could have flow until you die you know
but in the cycle you know just not on
the high the whole time
but go on right which makes it a
particularly powerful third solution yes
maybe my ration is what is your opinion
on pursuing a kind of synthesis of
relative love repeatedly engaging in
creative pursuits mutualist like in a
mutual relationship with other people as
a way to sustain so you just provided
the solution necessary no no no see what
you've said right now I just got the
goosebumps because it's you know I think
the whole thing in life as far as mental
health is concerned is DIY right like
we're all [ __ ] trying to figure it
out and the jazz musician has a solution
the basketball player has a solution the
surfer has a solution I mean they're all
the Bodhisattvas telling you this is the
way my son learn how to surf this wave
learn how to box get a workout in like
everybody's promising you the thing the
flow the hide aw but there are certain
things that tend to constantly trigger
it well no matter what type of flow is
what activity specifically gets you the
flow there's a universal flow trigger
which is novelty so a new experience
tends to put you into flow even if you
hadn't decided if that's your activity
that you love doing but but in fact that
it's new will probably be a flow trigger
so I have always thought if you combine
let's say travel
with a relationship you could probably
renew the excitement of meeting them for
the first time by changing the backdrop
instead of having to change the person
you change the backdrop and the person
comes into view again because of the
flow induced by travel and then if you
want to even be more DIY well you know
then you know you add a little bit of an
intoxicant here and there to italicize
the experience you know it sounds like
you're offering an enticing opportunity
for the next contender it's gonna be
like oh my god we have to go travel the
world I mean hasn't that always been the
dream as you want to like see a sunset
like sitting on a sailboat in some like
remote island like the halo of the now
dude the sacred timeless moment the
moment that exists outside of time right
Golden Hour veneer again if music be the
food of love play on
wow so I was had a similar question to
him about you seem like you go into
these relationships thinking they're
gonna end or that they have an end and
you haven't maybe found like that person
where you feel like it's that forever
and how would you imagine creating with
that person you know to is not really
stable whereas that third that gives
stability and normally you croak
co-create which is typically a baby but
what if it were like a project you know
a passion project together yeah well I
think in some ways I would say that that
sort of assumption or that relationship
with endings infinitude
is something that people come to terms
with at different times in their lives
you know some people maybe don't
experience it until they're on their
deathbed and lucky them
they lived in the present the whole time
they never worried that things were
gonna end until they fully ended but
still they had a lot of bliss throughout
I think that your expectations and your
assumptions about finitude are
determined by early childhood
experiences right because when you're a
child you live in the Garden of Eden
when you're a child you live outside of
time that's kind of what's wonderful
about the childlike consciousness and
you know I remember my mom told me this
story that uh you know we lived in
Venezuela so when we go to the US like
twice a year one of the exciting things
about going to the US if you go to the
toy store you know they didn't have toys
stores like that and then as well I like
Toys R Us and and so but maybe because I
was learning I learned from a young age
that you know we only go to the u.s.
twice a year and then therefore we're
only there for a short amount of time
before we go back to Venezuela and so
there's only a certain amount of days
that you can go to the toy store so I go
to the toy store and I used to get
anxiety going in because I'm so
overwhelmed by all the options then I go
back to my mommy like can we stay here
infinite time because I already had like
a relationship with the tension that
like I couldn't be there indefinitely
and you know that clearly stems from
something in my childhood I don't know
if it was the early divorce of my
parents you know or just an acutely
sensitive kid that asks too many
questions about the way of things but
certainly there was a realization a
shattering of the Garden of Eden early
on and and and and I think it has to do
also with feeling unsafe at an early age
right because when you're young you're
supposed to be made to feel completely
protected which is the illusion of
eternity your parents are gods and
goddesses you live outside of time
they're omnipotent and you live in a
gated paradise you know that keeps the
chaos at bay but any type of illness at
an early age of a parent or a divorce or
anything that shatters that important
illusion to make you a well-adjusted
person with low levels of neurotic
if that is shattered that's the
beginning of pathology you know it's
it's it's it's the waking up into hell
so to speak and then you spend the rest
of your life trying to recapture that
feeling of feeling safe and feeling held
and feeling protected and it's like what
drug what trip what person what piece of
art can return me to that feeling you
know so it's like you know I wouldn't be
Who I am and done the work that I have
done I guess if things would have been
different but it's also meant a lot of a
lot of trials and tribulations along the
way okay Alexis oil flow Vienna
differente condo NOLA in glioma in sepia
that's also true she's saying that flow
is easier in your native tongue they
heard ayahuasca they got excited I'm
gonna try to answer that well the short
answer is I have not drank ayahuasca I
know that it's become very trendy as of
late Carl Jung has a great line about in
Theo genex and which is why I think that
the highly controlled way in which
they're doing it in these trials with
psilocybin and stuff are the way to go
he says beware of unearned wisdom okay
and Jordan Peterson quoted Carl Jung
would ask the same question be aware of
unearned wisdom because you might be you
might not be a vessel that can handle
that divine fluid it's like the Ark of
the Covenant right
yeah God is in there but if you look at
it you die you know so I just think that
is their healing to be found in plant
medicine
that's why civilizations for millennia
have employed these tools but they also
had very fixed containers for them and I
think people getting together in a
Brooklyn apartment with some shaman
tourists they brought from Brazil who's
giving everybody I don't I just don't
know if that ticks the boxes of a safe
container and I worry about the
irresponsible use because I think in the
desire to heal trauma these medicines
can also cause trauma and and so even
though I'm Pro research a hundred
percent I am NOT Pro casual when it
comes to this stuff hi so much but I
guess the interest of keeping it short
and focusing on suffrage and full
incoming well-rounded with plant
medicine are you ask a relationship to
self intrinsic behavior how your body
responds responds what's going on from
the outside
speaking about Michael Pollan and food
and the interest of AI and what the goal
is I mean they're looking at AI now for
treatment for pain because we're not
understanding where pain is actually
coming from but we understand that if
we're in AI or if we're in psychedelics
then we're gonna be developing neural
pathways we're gonna be training our
body we're gonna be creating this
delicious response
hence through structure and guidance
that we can find some tangible traction
to ease the suffrage hence suffrage I'm
a huge plant-based person and I'm very
interested in the human relationship to
toxin toxin development calcification of
the pineal gland the lack of
acknowledgment to the psoas muscle which
is our intrinsic response to fright and
flight and terror so if the glass is
gonna fall my so as is telling me first
catch the glass
but nobody's paying attention to the
psoas muscle and it continues to go away
now I get this isn't the context in the
space to do it and I'm really excited
about AI I get to be a TechCrunch this
year in San Francisco for some crazy
stuff it's just like part of the future
at the exact same time we have to pay
attention to our food we have to pay
attention to what is causing our system
to sleep and to be quiet to need the
need of AI when our body is in suffrage
when we eat the food that we are given
to eat the first place of suffrage we
have is extinction you like movies I get
it
forgive me because I'm on the mic they
have the goblet you take the cyanide no
you take the syenite now who's gonna die
first Oh guess what we both have it I've
just been building up my body's
protection to this so in the
relationship to toxicity in food how do
we find access to this when most of this
stuff causes our body to sleep causes us
to be debilitated it causes the disease
the cancer and the pain on top of the
emotional aspect of why do people have
breast cancer well most women have
breast cancer because hi we bear the
burden of the world and we have these
two nectars that provide and it encases
our heart my heart is breaking on her
can't handle it so it moves the energy
from your heart it puts it to your
breast where it can be disseminated
where it actually gets touch where it
actually gets acknowledged where and
actually gets all of so in short I don't
know if there's a question but I think
no I think you thank you for sharing
yeah
because it is all intrinsic and
connected and we want to be connected
and we want to sit with the medicine
plan but you can't sit with plant and
toxin right
so yeah let's have people work out a way
that we can have these things to support
this but if we're supporting it through
the dissemination of toxins which is
gonna stagnate our liver which is gonna
mess up our kidneys which is gonna screw
our adrenals which is gonna make women
have thyroid problems crazy with the
lack of wheat like I know you know so
what she got brah come to Oakland no I'm
kidding thank you hi Jason
my name is Marcel I'm from Brazil Amy
I'd like to ask you a more sober
question it's a little bit off the topic
and why was discussed here but I really
would like to hear your thoughts in
regards to the duality that now we have
so much access to material things and I
think most of all of us here in this
room would say they're living a
comfortable life compared to others and
I think San Francisco is the perfect
example of this duality how do you feel
I just love to hear your thoughts in
regard to this perspective that we're
constantly looking for success trying to
reach her best and have those happiness
moments working on these companies you
know driving these cars and doing other
stuff while at the same time seeing so
much poverty so much people needing your
help and at the same time having to
suffocate that inner soul that screams
help this guy in the street right and
I'll say I'm a hypocrite I would say
that well no but I mean why do you feel
about having to suffocate those feelings
in our soul to help those people at the
same time human soul not empowered to do
anything because that's it's just a big
problem in the bigger scale thank you
yeah no I think the feeling is one of
total impotence and it's a
I think that empathy rarely extends
beyond our line of sight so I think the
solution for most people is just not to
look there whether consciously or
unconsciously another coping strategy
even though it's true but it's still a
coping strategy is to tell yourself the
world is better than it's ever been
yes they're suffering but there's a lot
less than there used to be and hundreds
of millions of people leave poverty
every day it's just maybe not happening
at the rate in America but certainly in
Southeast Asia and other places people
are leaving poverty at a rapid rapid
rapid rate is we don't live there we
don't see it but all in all human
progress is astounding by every
measurable indicator so you know you
walk down the street you see a homeless
person you're like how is it possible
this is so horrible it's so sad you feel
impotent
maybe you tell yourself that like
overall things are getting better
certainly doesn't help that person but
it helps you to feel less guilty when
you continue to walk and do your thing I
think that's what people do right what
else can they do
unless you've said that you can help
that one person but then what about the
150 million that you're not helping so I
mean I suffer the same way with this as
you and every time I see a person that
doesn't seem well it feels like all of
my concerns and ambitions and goals are
called into question and seem
meaningless and I didn't feel like a
hypocrite I mean I share with you that
sensation and and I don't really have a
solution you know I mean I don't I I
struggle with that daily yeah I'm just
saying that there's a we get to wrap Q&A
up yeah we got a wrap QA oh thank you
thank you thank you very much guys thank
you
[Applause]
for those that are VIP please stick
around we'll have a new company yeah
thank you guys Jason for those that are
VIP please stick around up here in the
front also for those that weren't aware
we were streaming this onto YouTube and
Facebook so if you go to Jason's Twitter
you can find the link to the video there
share it with other people and let's
extend the conversation further follow
us on simulation series.com we are
featuring Naveen Jain at the beginning
of September which will be a very
exciting show and thanks everyone for
coming out and continuing the
conversation much love to you all thank
you great job Alan that was good high
five